The Incredibles are back with a brand new
teaser trailer for the super-long-awaited
sequel!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and in this video I'm going to break down
the new teaser for Pixar's Incredibles 2.
I'm really excited for this movie; I love
the style of the animation and the score by
Michael Giacchino is just gorgeous, so I can't
wait to see and hear lots more of that!
The way the teaser kicks off will feel familiar
to you if you've watched Pixar's short film
Jack-Jack Attack, where you'll have seen the
Parr Family's youngest child pass through
solid objects like he does here.
Notice in the teaser footage that when Jack-Jack
uses his laser vision, it's green, whereas
in Jack-Jack Attack, it's actually purple.
I wonder if there's a significant reason behind
that change of colour, or whether it's that
the filmmakers think this new colour looks
better with the rest of the new movie, or,
perhaps most likely, it's just because the
background in this teaser is red and Jack-Jack's
laser vision wouldn't have stood out as clearly
against that if it had been purple instead
of the green colour they've gone for here.
I thought it was really fun the way they use
Jack-Jack to create the movie's new logo from
the old one.
So we see Jack-Jack using his Laser Vision
to split the single 'i' to create two 'i's,
which is a really cool and clever way to show
visually that this is the second film, Incredibles
2.
And it was also funny later in the clip when
he zaps his dad, splitting his hair in two
down the middle in a similar way.
We already saw Jack-Jack unleash a variety
of superpowers in front of his babysitter
and against the villainous Syndrome in both
the first Incredibles feature film and the
short film.
But his parents didn't see those powers because
when Syndrome was battling the baby high up
in the sky, Jack-Jack's family were on the
ground below.
However, at the very end of The Incredibles,
we did see Jack-Jack don a mask, like the
rest of his family, seemingly ready to do
battle with the villain The Underminer, who
was voiced by Pixar's good-luck-charm, John
Ratzenberger.
And that's exactly where the new movie will
pick up too.
"Behold the Underminer!"
"I hereby declare war on peace and happiness!"
Some Incredibles 2 footage that screened at
D23 this summer showed Jack-Jack using his
powers against a raccoon, and his father Bob
waking up and cheering 'He has powers'.
And if you compare that to this new teaser
trailer, it sounds a little like this is a
variation of the end of that D23 footage.
"You have powers!"
"Yeah, baby!"
I love the way in this teaser that his father
is so proud of his son's superhero abilities.
And I also love the way that Jack-Jack seems
to sneeze here which causes him to course
through a range of his powers in a similar
way to how he seemed to hiccup in Jack-Jack
Attack just before he turned into a fire-ball,
showing perhaps that he's not in complete
control yet of all his powers!
"Hic!"
It's a shame we don't get to see the whole
family in the teaser, though I'm sure we'll
see more of them in the first full trailer.
According to writer-director Brad Bird, Elastigirl
will be at the forefront of the action in
the new feature, while Bob Parr, aka Mr Incredible,
'has to stay home facing his biggest challenge
yet', and I'm guessing that some of that challenge
will be linked to what we've just seen in
this teaser and the revelation of Jack-Jack's
superpowers.
So, how excited are you for Incredibles 2?
And what did you think of the teaser trailer?
Let me know in the comments below.
Make sure you subscribe and turn on notifications
to get all my new Disney and Pixar videos,
including Pixar's Coco later this week.
And tap the screen right here for more videos
I'm sure you'll enjoy!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!